où est passée la promesse du président
de la république de réconcilier les
français dans ces territoires
notre république n'a jamais été autant
fracturé dans son unité notre société
n'a jamais autant été attaqué attaqué
par une montée des communautarismes et
de l'islamisme radical
comme ce fut encore malheureusement le
cas ce dimanche avec cette manifestation
qui est venu défier la république de
manière intolérable
monsieur le premier ministre face à de
telles menaces vous ne pouvez plus
tergiverser
vous ne pouvez plus hésiter et vous ne
pouvais plus reculer
vous et votre gouvernement vous êtes
devenu prisonnier de votre propre marque
de fabrique
à savoir cette politique du en même
temps qui fait de l'indécision votre
principe d'action et de l'inaction votre
seul horizon
le sujet des retraites est un sujet qui
stresse la société française vous
entretenez une confusion extrême alors
que vous devriez être d'une clarté
extrême et plus personne n'y comprend
rien sur la forme
la méthode est lunaire pour savoir qui
sera concerné par cette réforme
et à partir de quand s'agira-t-il
seulement des nouveaux entrants c'est à
dire la fameuse clause de grand-père
avec une application dans 40 ans votre
méthode consiste essentiellement à
gagner du temps alors que vous y
travaillez depuis deux ans déjà les
débats parlementaires n'ont pas encore
commencé consiste déjà double recule
recule sur l'âge légal
hercules sur les régimes spéciaux le
président reconnaît que l'immigration
est un problème très bien c'est une
avancée et l'installent le sujet dans
son discours parfait on n'attendait que
ça mais c'est en réalité de la poudre
aux yeux
depuis deux ans la lutte contre
l'immigration illégale n'est absolument
pas une priorité du gouvernement
cent mille expulsions ont été ordonnées
en 2018 appel 12% ont été exécutés deux
cent cinquante six mille titres de
séjour ont été délivrés l'année dernière
c'est un record depuis 40 ans c'est
aussi et vous le savez une explosion des
demandes d'asile près de 25% en plus en
le projet de loi de finances
rectificative que vous venez de nous
présenter met fin aux dernières
illusions que vous entreteniez sur votre
sérieux budgétaire
non vous ne baissez pas la dépense
publique dans notre pays
les 1,5 milliard d'économies que vous
annonciez en décembre pour financer les
mesures d'urgence économique et social
sont purement abandonné après le
renoncement sur la maîtrise de la dette
qui atteint 99 % de la richesse
nationale
après vos renoncement sur la maîtrise
des comptes publics alors que le déficit
se creuse cette année pour la première
fois depuis dix ans c'est un renoncement
de plus c'est un renoncement de trop ce
n'est un secret pour personne les deux
grands perdants du quinquennat
d'emmanuel macron sont les retraités et
les familles et je veux parler
aujourd'hui de notre politique familiale
s'il ya bien un domaine dans lequel la
france excellait en comparaison avec ses
voisins européens c'est celui de la
natalité
et pourtant depuis plusieurs années
cette tendance est en train de
s'inverser
alors bien sûr il existe des réalités
sociologiques et des évolutions des
schémas de vie qui expliquent en partie
ce phénomène mais ces réalités
n'explique pas tout
cette baisse continue de la natalité est
également à mettre en lien avec la
dégradation de mots de notre modèle de
politique familiale à cette heure de
nombreux malades atteints de la maladie
de lyme
mais aussi les personnes qui souffrent
de symptômes pouvant leur laissait
craindre qu'elles sont atteintes se
retrouve en errance thérapeutique et
désespère d'obtenir des réponses à leurs
nombreuses interrogations dans le même
temps le nombre de nouveaux cas recensés
ne cesse d'augmenter
soixante sept mille nouveaux cas pour la
seule année 2010 8
pourquoi refusez-vous d'abonder le plan
lime et d'octroyer les crédits
nécessaires à la recherche
à l'heure où beaucoup d'autres pays se
saisisse de cette question
[Musique]